Voici mon Draw My Life 2 !
C'est pas parce que j'ai une deuxième vie,mais c'est parce que je voulais revenir sur certains moments de ma vie qui ont été importants.
Quand j'étais tout petit, les BD me fascinaient et j'adorais voir les dessins mais je savais pas lire.
Alors je dessinais des BD avec des bulles vides parce que je savais pas écrire
alors mes parents m'ont inscrit à un cours d'arts plastiques dans un centre culturel à Nice.
J'étais trop content parce que j'avais des feutres et des pinceaux neufs.
Je pense que mes parents aimaient bien se dire :
"Ouais stuveux mon fils il a une fibre artistique, il va des cours d'arts plastiques, c'est le plus jeune du cours..."
"Oui ? Mon fils ne veut pas dessiner ?"
"Et il veut plus jamais revenir au cours ? D'accord..."
"Ouais stuveux mon fils il va commencer le piano en fait."
"Ouais il a le sens de la mélodie, clairement..."
En fait, j'aimais pas qu'on me dise quoi et comment dessiner.
Et pour la blague mes parents m'ont acheté un piano avec leurs économies et je leur ai dit
"Je veux faire de la batterie."
Certifié : Enfant Relou.
on fait un bond en avant, j'ai 17 ans, je suis au lycée je passe mon temps à faire des dessins
que je poste sur mon blog, suivi par quelques personnes, c'est vrai...
et là je découvre les sites Dailymotion et Youtube, on peut poster des vidéos sur internet.
alors j'en parle à mes potes : "Hey les gars j'aimerais trop poster des vidéos sur internet !"
Et ils me disent : " super risqué de s'afficher devant tout le monde, on va voir ton visage et tout"
"et puis t'as pas de caméra"
Mais mes parents ont un caméscope !
Alors j'ai pas hésité, j'ai filmé un test de jeu, une musique, un sketch, bref ! Tout et n'importe quoi
"Attend mais Cyprien, t'as enregistré par dessus nos vidéos de vacances ?!"
"Écoutez Mère, mon art est plus important que vos vidéos futiles."
"Mais on avait des cassettes vierges en fait."
"Ouais je vais faire ça."
et soudain sur mon blog
"ARRÊTE LES VIDÉOS !"
c'est la première fois que je reçois un commentaire de ce genre.
Vous savez quoi ? Je ne l'ai pas écouté, mais ça vous êtes au courant.
Quelques mois plus tard j'entre à la fac à Aix-en-Provence
et tous mes temps libres sont consacrés à faire des vidéos
j'en ai posté des dizaines sur mon blog
et surprise dans ma boîte aux lettres
bon en vrai c'était dans mes mails
on m'invite à Paris à une convention pour ceux qui bossent sur internet :
des start-up, des graphistes et surtout d'autres créateurs vidéo
c'est la première occasion pour rencontrer des gens avec la même passion que moi
parce que oui, en 2007 on est très très peu nombreux mais vraiment très peu quoi
Mais la date tombe le même jour que mes examens.
Alors je peux pas y aller.
Donc j'y suis quand même allé. J'ai fait plein de rencontres et j'ai loupé mon semestre.
Je sais pas si c'est le hasard mais quelques semaines plus tard je reçois un mail
euh pardon... un mail. Voilà.
On me propose un boulot de monteur vidéo sur Paris
c'est super mais je suis en plein milieu de mes études et j'ai pas de diplôme
je me rappelle d'un étudiant de ma fac qui me disait que c'était une mauvaise idée d'arrêter les études
Donc j'ai accepté le job !
Je suis monté sur Paris pour travailler, j'en ai déjà parlé dans mon premier "draw my life"
tout en faisant des vidéos sur ma chaîne à côté.
C'était en 2008, l'année où j'ai fait la rencontre de Norman, Hugo, Kemar, PV Nova et Squeezie.
Non c'est pas vrai pour Squeezie. En 2008 il avait 12 ans
Je traînais pas avec lui.
On fait un bond de quelques années en avant, fin 2011
je travaille sur la chaîne télé d'histoire et de documentaires NRJ12
j'y fais une mini émission quotidienne, donc en gros
je fais une vidéo chaque jour pour la télé, et le week-end je fais des vidéos pour ma chaîne YouTube.
Et YouTube vient de mettre en place un système qui permet de rémunérer les créateurs
parce que oui, avant sur internet, on faisait des vidéos pendant des années juste pour le plaisir
à ce moment là, personne ne vit de vidéos postées sur internet, j'ai même pas 200.000 abonnés
on peut pas se lancer dans un métier qui n'existe pas.
Alors je le fais. Je pose ma démission au milieu de la saison
mes collègues me disent que plein de gens rêvent de bosser à la télé
et que c'est pas très judicieux de quitter ce boulot
Mais moi je le vois pas le risque, je vois juste du fun, du temps pour faire mes vidéos et des rencontres.
Et ce genre de décision, je suis pas le seul à les prendre :
Monter sur scène face à des milliers de personnes ? Fais-le.
Rencontrer le Dalaï Lama ? Fais-le.
Faire de la musique sans instrument ? Fais-le.
Du cinéma sans avoir un seul contact ? Fais-le.
Expliquer l'inexplicable ? Fais-le.
Aujourd'hui je repense à tous les commentaires qui peuvent paraître décourageants
et ça me donne encore plus envie d'avancer et d'être créatif.
Et j'ai enfin trouvé quoi mettre dans la bulle de mon petit personnage :
Si ça te paraît impossible, fais-le quand même.